welcome everybody to the h3 podcast
today we have a very special episode
here with the people who are responsible
for birthing me and we have my mom Donna
I know can we get a whale away oh wait
wait we got my dad the Garry kleiner hey
now hey and of course the original the
greatest partner in crime ela kleiner
why don't you dance before we get
started I just want to give a quick
thank you to our sponsors love these
guys they support the show they make all
this possible guys appreciate them - uh
we got today naturebox
Dollar Shave Club and me undies
oh those undies I want to get some of
those I gotta pee yeah we're gonna talk
about it okay we got a lot to talk about
more about them later but thank you to
those guys yes we'll get into all that
that's important
how you guys doing how was the drive it
wasn't bad yeah it was not too bad in
our new car it was nice being able to
take the diamond lane rather than as I
usually do monthly come out by myself so
this is the first time you guys have
come down to LA together just so you
guys know they literally drove here from
Vegas and this was your first stop it
was yes yeah you know well I thought it
was going to take six hours but it took
us four and a half if I drove it would
have been six is too long to be fair
like we're something you guys have
driving habits they scared me equally on
in honesty I figure the six hours from
from our house to Jessica's this is a
lot shorter there Eunice I did have to
stop ones for mom to pee which I never
do when I Drive you didn't even get out
to be you like I'm on Princeton you're
like hardcore yeah in the meantime when
we got here you barely make it to the
bathroom right down the hallway well you
guys weren't late so thank you for that
early but like so when I'm driving with
my mom on the
every way she's in like the middle lane
and so she got so slow that cars are
passing us that like great velocity your
graphic well I appreciate you driving
slow but I'm also a little this feels
safe your grandfather says I'm a fast
driver any-anything thinks your uncle
Stephen is a slow driver can you quick
and dangerous one yeah my brother's the
one they taught me how to drive - my
mom's driving like 50 on the freeway no
when I come out here in LA 65 is its
suggested should be in the slow lane if
ya doing 65 yeah but then on the other
hand my dad I'll never forget when we
were in Mexico you guys live in Mexico
oh yeah as you guys know about you guys
may not know and you were you you're
like a nut on the road I remember like
that was the first time you were there
yeah and my dad is speeding like people
say in Mexico the drivers that are
unsafe it's unsafe to drive Mexico my
dad is the reason it's unsafe I remember
we're rounding a corner and like the car
was like tipping oh yeah because we have
the route door it's it's a box
that's a good car and it's what I call
defensive offensive Drive there was
nobody on the road we were on the
Chipola highway going from Lake Chapala
to Guadalajara probably the little
winding road yes people the people that
drive in Mexico are very polite they
don't have any road rage the the roads
are insane because when I use the lanes
yeah everything suggested and when I
used to be the designated driver when my
girlfriends and I went to Guadalajara
which shows you what good drivers there
we would go to tlaquepaque and when I
had to make a left-hand turn I just roll
down the window and go thank you thank
you and they just say come on Lady just
come on in
but they were really nice the Mexicans
are great people they were very more
polite drivers than we are here
yeah but the roads are terrifying there
because they have like huge wide lanes
and no markings right and then they've
got these crazy thing where they've got
like an island and then you have to like
there's like oh oh when you make a left
turn you have to go all the way to the
right right they have what they call
laterals which means when you want to
make a left turn you have to go way over
to the right wait for the left-turn
arrow and then go across six lanes of
traffic that you hope will stop for the
life right it's crazy not the safest
thing it's pretty it's pretty crazy that
you're right dad's a crazy driver he's
always been a crazy driver don't believe
them
Oh God dude and like my dad elephants
with the BB gun go ahead okay good all
right we'll lay it on then hit a [ __ ]
but like you do this thing where we're
all in the car and we're like please
slow down
I'm scared I'm actually scared please
slow down and then you just like no I
hold on to shut up and hold on to the
side you know that little handle on that
no [ __ ] handle yeah I hold on to it
that's fear I've never heard anyone
scream please slowed oh okay
maybe I just never paid attention to
anyone get in the zone slow down you
don't hear anything just the road
concentrate yeah yeah now that his
vision is really good yeah you guys well
mom you're you haven't come down here
you can say hi then can do mind showing
it you don't have to it's pretty good
it's interesting oh I guarantee you
everyone watching this has seen
something grosser than that
can you see it yeah that's gnarly and if
he's all bloody because it's like
dripping down my dripping down my my arm
but now it works wait what do you mean
it was dripping down your all the blood
cuz this whole thing is filled with wait
you have blood drip out of the wound no
it's all swollen and it's filled with
blood and they lose my arm they this is
like nothing holy Wow it's the whole
thing is just dripping down my my mom
recently got butchered by a shitty dog I
don't know yeah I mean it's hard how do
you feel you must be very ambivalent
about it well you know I I don't know I
don't know what to think
I keep I'm thinking maybe I didn't need
a pacemaker but then and but then I
realized that I did need a pacemaker but
it's just all that stuff that happened
afterwards that what happened can you
tell the story from like the beginning
okay well I woke up one morning and my
heart stopped and so I passed out and
and your I called grandpa to let him
know I wasn't gonna be able to make it
how long ago was this this was it
October 23rd
it was October 23rd so it was about
eight months ago nine months ago this
has been going on for nine months oh
well you know it takes a while to
recover well you're better now I mean
five surgeries in nine months it's a lot
of surgery so anyway so I called your
grandfather cuz you know I wanted it I
do things with grandpa once a week and
wanted to let him know I wasn't gonna
make it and apparently I must have
sounded funny and he called your sister
Jessica who in turn called your brother
Sean who you know was living out in
Vegas at the time and threatened his
life if he didn't come and check up on
me
well the meantime I called your father
and he was driving back from from here
and
dad was like well what the hell that's
exactly where let me get a straight you
were driving back yeah daddy's driving
whoo
you think he's like that I wasn't Oaks
when mom called and I could tell
something was you were wrong you were
far off yeah yeah he's really far right
away yeah I mean what can you do you're
you're not there right exactly except
panic which anyways so I went when the
paramedics came and I was kind of
arguing with them saying you know I
think it was food poisoning and and
during this whole time like I was
passing out and coming to and passing
out and he told me he informed me
because they had a thing on me to check
my heart chief yeah and he said he says
madam your heart stopping so unless we
get you to the hospital now you're gonna
die and so if you'd like to stay here
you can sign this release which is when
of course I had the Epiphany III think I
should go to the hospital don't sue us
when you die yeah that's some heavy-duty
[ __ ] yeah my mom is the type of person
to be like it's it's indigestion right
from the get-go that's how she was and
she's a horrible storyteller but I I you
know I called Sean who is planning to go
on a hike after he talked to Jessica and
he was like yeah okay I'll go by you
know after I'm done with the hike and I
called Sean and said this is not a test
you need to get to the house right now
cuz the end house key of course and go
over there and see how mom is so he went
over there and he called me goes well
she doesn't want to go to the hospital
and she doesn't want me to call the
paramedics and I said how is she looking
he goes she's bad and I said tell her if
she doesn't go with you you're calling
the paramedics and she's going so that's
what he ended up doing and then she's
still fighting him yeah when they got
there and that was when Sean called us
right yeah that was Sean goes he said
Ethan asked him like so how bad is it
what is happening because we're in LA
right so we'll have to drive if it's a
real emergency and so Sean was like well
she's not gonna die
the next five probably not gonna die in
the next don't worry we got in the car
medially I when I when I went to the
emergency room and I said to the nurse
they're putting all this stuff on me and
you know am i joking my clothes off so
so much I guess my heart was stopping
and they had me monitored on the you
know on the cardia on the on the EKG
whatever the thing anyways so I said I
think it's indigestion she put honey
your sac
I went really anyway so that's what
happened and then I did all of a sudden
I woke up I mean I must have been out
and yeah I was there I don't know how
you got there so fast you believe like
lost your memory once you got to the
hospital I just kept on passing out cuz
my heart was stopping jihad something
fast I Drive fast normally yeah a little
fast know what we were driving ah zero
both although I mean how fast we're
driving I didn't go over ninety you know
by the CHP or no way patrol yeah which
would slow me down so you know sometimes
when you're driving from LA to Vegas you
get in a good pack of people that yeah
it's like in the Tour de France when you
have a good line of good hello and
people move over people pass people move
back and I got in a really good group of
people and we think their safety numbers
of course but we've also all seen five
or six people speeding pulled over at
the same time so don't don't fall for
that truck I've never got a speeding
ticket actually have anything how many
have you gotten deer speeding tickets
okay how many tickets have you got I'm
making your lifetime crashes have you
been in mmm-hmm how many I think how
many of you been in mom zero point how
many mirror dad a million how many miles
have you driven mom a hundred you know
he says to me you haven't been driving
as long as me no matter what I haven't
been on a mile five years apart it's not
it's not the age it's how many miles
you've driven the more miles you drive
increases your probability of having it
like pulling out in the middle of street
making a left-hand turn and getting hit
oh and Topanga Boulevard huh that was
like 30 years ago yes you know we
newlyweds meet yeah a lot of marriage
counseling so you woke up in the
hospital so I woke up in the hospital
and all of a sudden dad was there Shawn
was there obviously and they told me I
needed a pacemaker I had this thing
called sick sinus syndrome and what it
is is when your heart doesn't beat
correctly so like my heart was beating
and then it was like well I don't feel
like beating for a while so your heart
just pauses for like five seconds ten
seconds but after a while it you know
that could be really dangerous and you
could die so we I ended up much to the
chagrin of the of mice of my son the
doctor gave me this test he asked me a
bunch of questions and then he told me
after he you know I answered them that I
failed the test and I said well you know
my knew he was going to give me a cat
well no he was just asking me questions
like okay well you could here's this
problem with her heart why did she pass
out why did her heart stop
like how wonderful three things so yeah
he asked the questions wrong and then
she says can I take the test again like
it's a multiple-choice and she just
picked she could have voided the surgery
so then okay so then they go ahead and
they do the surgery and the doctor
during the surgery
punctured my left lung that's the
greatest the best twist over 5% chance
of that happening yeah I told everyone I
needed buy a lotto ticket cuz my my odds
so that was the worst part about your
recovery she went in because her heart
stopped beating are you
you're having heart failure of some sort
right right and then when they're
installing the pacemaker the doctor
[ __ ] you got doctor shaky hands over
everything right they run a wire lead
from your heart you know into it's
really close to your lung in fairness to
the doctor and I'm really from unlike me
you I'm really thin so it's it happened
so he just he made a blow poke on your
lawn and then it just heard you're her
lung completely collapsed completely
collapsed so I was stuck in the ICU for
like I think was eight days yeah so she
had the the pacemaker here and then they
had to put another hole in it yeah I had
to go so the doctor cut the
pulmonologist comes in two into my room
and he says okay I'm here for the
emergency I go what emergency he goes
you're the emergency I go what he
because your lung is completely
collapsed in your right lung is starting
to collapse now unless you want to be on
a respirator we need to operate so the
nurse says doctor when do you want me to
prep her and he says yesterday so so
then so then I I said nobody told me
that I even had a punctured lung that it
collapsed I just think because we're
going in anyway so I had to be up for
this did you feel out of breath like did
you have any sense the minute I got out
of the operating room the nurse said to
me how do you feel I said I can't
breathe I feel nauseous and my shoulder
which I had a torrent they tore my
rotator cuff I said it feels like my
left shoulder was put in a vise and it
was putting a bite I don't know if it
was put in a vise he dislocated yours
well no they didn't dislocate it they
just they just hurt my my rotator cuff I
guess because I was up you know I mean
they didn't completely put me out during
the surgery so I guess somebody must
have been holding me down or I don't
know I don't know so then the saga
continues so I've got a tube in my back
which is so uncomfortable because you
can't lean back because you've got a
ring near the back of your rib cage into
your lung right they have to put off
they have to put a hole into your lung
and they
fish it through your ribcage so then and
then it was draining you know all those
lovely stuff and then they let me go
home but in my stay there they said you
have you're developing a cardial temp
innate and what that is nice kind of a
little tamponade yeah so what was
happening was around your heart you have
like this inner tube and it's your
pericardium and in usually you have a
little tiny bit of fluid in there and it
helps to keep your heart safe when it's
beating it kind of bounces off of it and
it keeps it nice and safe pericardial
sac right but what happened to me is my
pericardial sac filled up with so much
fluid that it's around your heart and it
was squeezing my heart so the right side
of my heart was collapsing it was
literally squishing my heart so it
couldn't be [ __ ] after going through all
this we go back Monday for the for the
follow-up visit to the doctor right and
he discovers this pressure on her heart
and we went from the doctor's office
downstairs into a wheelchair wheeled
next door to the hospital back industry
let me clarify 20 minutes and I was on
what's the hospital you got the
pacemaker you had a your lung collapse
right then you were in there for eight
days as your lung healed right right
then you went home my lungs still had my
lung was actually filling with fluid
which I didn't know about it yeah
everything's fine so you went home well
yeah yes and you weren't feeling well
well they told me that I had to come
normally you don't come back after
something like that for a couple of days
but they said you know you're you're
developing this this cardial tamponade
and we just want to make sure so they
knew there was there was instructions
that when I came in that I had to have a
a chest x-ray and when I had the checks
right x-ray the doctor doctor read shout
out to dr. ray yes thank you dr. rush
came in and said okay yeah I said to him
do I have time to go home and get a
change of clothes and he just said no we
literally went downstairs he put her in
a wheelchair the hospital is right next
door to the medical office when the
doctor is wheeled her next door boom
into the operating room again yeah went
home for the weekend yeah you went back
for a routine checkup right and they're
like you need to go your hearts beating
heart is being crushed yesterday jokes
about how you're dying
we're in a banter free zone I was
texting and putting things on Facebook
there was trying to keep it light yeah
mom didn't feel as bad as she actually
was so it was a surprise to us to find
that out so I felt right back right back
into the ER and you know what that was
that was after we came to Vegas yeah
yeah you're going home yeah we thought
you were fine and we're like okay we can
leave yeah because the second surgery
was that was way bad we got really
worried after the second one because
that's when you started to like be like
The Walking Dead
yeah I lost so much weight oh my god and
then and then after that okay so they
had to put a hole in my my pericardium
so I had to coming out of my chest and
it was draining you know fluid blood all
that other stuff and then the nurses
insisted because I was in so much pain
that I have an opiate like a drip oh
this is great don't know the process oh
my god they did it and I I I went out my
blood pressure went 72 over 20 to wait
it was good or bad I don't that's bad so
they gave me opioids to kill the Pantano
peon an opiate drip and then your blood
pressure crashed okay which was already
low
it was already low but it crashed and
totally crashed and so they I ended up I
had to have a transfusion oh Christ
it wasn't a blood transfusion I forgot
what they call it but there's a line
that goes all the way up your shoulder
and it's like it's like manufactured
some kind of some kind of thing anyways
so I found out I was not to ever take
opium or an opiate now you tell me the
doctor walks yeah we should have found
that out yesterday yeah I can still take
it it's like a character from Family Guy
so then then wait the saga continues
only a two-hour show okay so then what
happens was I finally get out of the
hospital and dad and I you know I
couldn't run or exercise so the best
thing I could do was walk and we were
out in a walk with with with our dog
dulce and our beautiful Rhodesian
Ridgeback and I had to stop we were in
this field and I had to stop and sit
down because I was so winded I was
having so much trouble breathing and it
turned out that my lung my left lung had
filled up with so much fluid it was 2.5
liter point one meters late that's like
a full bottle like 10% of her body
weight yeah holy in my left lung we saw
the picture there oh yeah that's right
put the pictures of the bottle filled
with fluid yeah I never think about
cracking that open it buttons do not
drink this now
nothing is going to mix well yeah so
they are supposed to drink long fluid
before after clear there we go never
been okay I never drink so I don't know
drinkers rhymes so so I knew something
was wrong anyways so I had to go and bit
to the back to the hospital
and they had to they take this like four
inch needle you were you ever did you
when you saw that neither do you ever be
like I'd rather die you know what David
show it to me they were smart I had my
back to it to the doctor I had was
holding on to this table and they let
dad yeah oh this is when you rush the
hospital they were gonna suck the fluid
out of your lung wasn't rush but it was
yeah I was getting I was drowning okay
this is when they suck the fluid out of
your lung right yeah 2.1 liters yeah so
dad was it was like a table like this
only you know it's like half what color
was it was it was kind of like beer
somewhere like a dark amber it kind of
looked like I saw some green was the
green yeah it was mine I can do that's
gross no nightmares I got a bottle that
I'm telling you there's demand that's me
in fact like a bunch of like poor ass
like Chinese people and just like farm
their lung fluid
there's gotta be a way to make money off
of it so anyway I remember you tell me
about the process of so okay so I'm in
the hospital room and there's a table
about this this slide like you know
dad's on the other side and I'm and the
doctors coming at me with this four inch
needle you didn't see it
that's I didn't see a dad's side were
you like oh [ __ ] when you saw it
was more glad it's not me and they stick
it in you between your ribs you make it
your MyPage it's a safety of fiction
they like stab a running start yeah it
was like wow and then rosanna arquette
said that was [ __ ] freaking it yeah
yeah it was like and then all sudden
yeah holy [ __ ]
cuz all the fluid started coming out of
me I never freaked out okay but you said
holy [ __ ] I might have said that I
wasn't freaking out okay was it the
stuff that her or the stabbing or
everything because I remember you told
me something hurt it hurt till they till
they were almost done yeah they said
they said when he starts to hurt let us
know and it hurt so bad I couldn't even
talk oh my god it was just really awful
good so then so that was done and then
they and then later on they told me that
my right lung was starting to fill up
with fluid but fortunately I went home
and I started doing some yoga you know
cuz my my might insert my other
incisions were healing so I started
doing yoga and I still have a little bit
of fluid left in my right long but
mutton I didn't have to yeah I didn't
have to get zapped yet Pulp Fiction so
then I go home and I'm getting speaking
of being zapped it kind of feels like
the most intensed intense hiccup you've
ever had and it's like someone put it on
my abdomen and I'm getting jolted all
the time and it got to the point was
where I was getting jolted all day
you're talking about from from the
pacemaker oh yeah this is the final
chapter which is also just a it's like a
total system of failure yeah everything
went wrong
like if they never punctured your lung
you would have probably been recovered
and fine yeah but like and then the same
doctor who [ __ ] up my mom's shoulder
punctured her lung it turns out that
she had the pacemaker installed wrong
and it was electrocuting her she was
being electrocuted can you imagine that
[ __ ] off I don't think I was qualified
to be a doctor he's a butcher fingers
it's it's just what happens is sometimes
the wire is really close like it's near
a nerve in your heart and the the nerve
sends like signals and so I kept on
getting you know like like contractions
in my abdomen and it was and it wasn't
like just a little hiccup it was like
boom boom mom was like you know those of
us who took biology in high school when
you did the experiments where they pit
the Frog and then you pit that's a word
yeah it was the pit where you take a
probe and you stick it into the back of
the frog skull and kind of grind out
their brains have stopped it at that
point but then you can put electric
prods like in different parts of the
frog's brain as he is like move and his
foot move and yeah so that's how mom was
and she was like honestly horrible yeah
so that's the incision you guys are
seeing now cuz my mom just how long ago
was your mother it was ten days ago so
ten days ago they went back in and fixed
pacemakers and she's no longer being
electrocuted right right now what are
you doing dad you're ruining the show
sorry sure there you're on your phone
and now you're playing videos I'm
pulling up the comments here from what
we're doing but anyway enough do you
want me to pull my eyeball out and you
can see we're not ready okay so I'm fine
I'm in great shape well it might be so
okay anyway god bless you
nine months later you'll find I'm so
happy
I remember when um can you believe this
[ __ ] MSL docker actually was
installed it wrong like a hole after
everything it's like I did that's up
there was you tired in the show you
don't need to read the chat okay good
point good point point taken alright
well let's move on I'm fine I feel like
Frankenstein I remember when you you
came down to LA to see a doctor and it
was so tragic seeing you like that but
you really rebounded it was very like oh
I feel like no one knew if you were ever
gonna go back to that was there normal I
I wasn't sure either that was really she
was just a husk I mean right yeah plus
plus when when I had my lung drained I
was in so much pain they sent me home
without any pain medication and dad
insisted I was like holding on to the
bed but dad insisted and we went to the
hospital and then they misdiagnosed me
in one of the hospitals and said I was
going to have to have another surgery
remember that I remember that yeah I
remember you call me I'm gonna die oh my
god no literally you called me like I
have to get into surgery so I'm probably
gonna die I through usual optimism well
I mean there's just some wasn't much
optimism laughs degree although one
great little story I love to that you
that you I remember is that you were at
home taking some opioids and then the
doctor didn't tell you the consequence
of taking opioids for pain killers which
is this so if you take opioids it can
cause extreme constipation yep I have a
friend who was telling me he recently
had some kind of procedure and the
doctor did tell him that opioids cause
constipation why don't they say that you
really need to know they say it now in
their commercial which is now that we've
caused you to back up by selling you
opioids now we're gonna create
pill to unpack you up so you could buy
two pills from well I wish you sell me
that pill from the beginning let's go my
friend
his cost-efficient was so bad he didn't
[ __ ] for ten days and he had to go into
surgery he had to get actual surgery to
remove a brick of [ __ ] out of his
[ __ ] like eight careful with this
stuff you know or here take this
laxative alongside yeah I I avoided
taking I was taking percocet and I was
like and I was trying to I was trying to
like well do I really need it you know
cuz it backs you up it's good it works
but it's like oh my god yeah so I was
dad screaming take the pill now speaking
of painkillers I found an interesting
fact that you know our dog has a torn
ACL which is a very athletic injury to
get anterior cruciate ligament and the
doctor said well let's we'll give her an
anti-inflammatory and I said can we give
her ibuprofen advil no the only thing
you can give a dog that works on humans
and dogs is tramadol interestingly
enough yeah which I just happen to have
was it 50 50 50 milligrams I think
that's so weird trail just works yeah
yeah but don't give your dog to anything
that's not good for you the only one
that works for humans and dogs
interestingly for some reason the
thought of giving a dog a serious
painkiller is seen as kind of funny but
does a pain how does it how was she
unlike yeah I'm sure they do but like
how is she yeah only giving her tour a
couple times I haven't really seen her
been in a lot of pain and she's pretty
well you know what in the evening when I
see her going from room to room I know
she's trying to get comfortable and I'd
say to dad give her a pain pill hook her
up hook her up exactly again some drug
pusher I know I don't want my baby to be
in pain
so you okay well not not to be outdone
let's talk about your grievances dead
yeah this is getting all episode hold
all your listeners are gonna be tuning
at I was here Joe Rogan's say this and I
agree if it's interesting to me it's
interesting to them right how can I do I
can't think about like oh do people find
this interesting if it's interesting to
me then that's as good as I can help I
can't they're engaged interesting tell
me more about constipation yeah
and during the same time you started
having some weird [ __ ] in your eye yeah
right after mom was pretty much done
with everything which is actually a
great story
I love the treatment for that you know
most people when they get a little older
start to get what they call floaters in
your I was just like squiggly looks kind
of like spermatozoa sperm you know
floating around your eye but it got
beyond that at some point and I knew
something was wrong and I I didn't
procrastinate as I have a normal habit
of doing I waited two days and then I
went to the eye doctor said oh you looks
like you've got a detached retina and
that's something that if you don't take
care of immediately you will go blind
and that eye right in that eye so I went
to the optometrist Wednesday on Friday I
went into surgery and they knock you out
and what the treatment is is they put a
little nitrogen bubble in the back of
your eyeball and that attaches to the
retina which is in the very back of your
like it said if you looked at your eye
it would be like a three o'clock
you know in in your eye socket so what
that means is you have to keep your head
you know position Center you have to be
like looking down all the time including
when you're sleeping so you have to
spend at least 21 out of 24 hours a day
looking down at the ground position
which for someone like me who sleeps on
their back who still is not they'll
sleep on their stomach or who sleep even
if you sleep on your stomach you don't
put your
yeah I wouldn't have been able to do it
I've never heard this in my life doctor
says my dad you have to keep your head
down
how long was it for a week I like this
company bottom a massage table baby ba
yeah you can rent it actually yeah good
how much that run you 200 bucks store
the whole week yeah still waiting for it
Humana
hello still waiting for my check back
from you guys but anyway who's that
let's caught listen let's get it so it
comes in two parts one is like kind of
like a massage chair with last thing you
can put your face down a little mirror
so you can watch TV imagine my laptop
down there in a little table and then it
also has it's kind of like a push-up bar
you know you've seen those things where
you do really good push-up pose it
elevate you from the ground so that's
what the thing that you slept in
basically was so you put your head in
there but then because you're sleeping
with your head elevated then your back
starts to hurt because you're sleeping
at a weird angle
did you try to experiment with putting
pillows under your chest to raise your
body and I'd wait I'd wake up in the
middle of the night and dad wouldn't
have his head in the right position and
and of course compared to what mom had
been through this I can't complain I'm
not getting any sympathy so I'm just I'm
sure was miserable but you can't
complain yeah oh god in the hospital
that he was in he was in these hospital
gowns that were made of some weird
material and poor dad broke out in hives
from hid from from his own Hospital
which shall remain nameless which didn't
do well by their own right now
yeah I called them in I mean you know I
just wanted to mention I'm getting I
think I got a rash from the hospital gun
because I'm not really allergic anything
it went oh yeah we know about that oh
that's smallpox no no it's just somebody
was just I mean it was just
are you supposed to wash those you
wouldn't open a hospital Duncan heart
this is the same hospital that kept them
busted my mom open and now they're
sending out smallpox blankets
well that was acts
that wouldn't give her pain meds I've
been I've been into five what's your
review of hospitals in Vegas you know
what it all depends on the doctor but
I'd say the best care that I got was
probably well you know what it's funny
because I Centennial hospital the nurses
were amazing that was the first hospital
where I had the you know the bad but
they really they were incredible and
never actually tearing you up in country
yeah but but it wasn't a nurses fault
and then Mountain View was okay well
yeah you can't fault the hospital for
one yeah yes but yeah so Summerlin
hospital she didn't say that why is the
Summerlin hospital was great you know
how much it cost for paramedics to come
and pick you up and dry now about three
miles from our house of clothes Mountain
to to Centennial Hospital yeah you know
you thought was in dollars no it was
more than that thousand like a bargain
for five minutes they charged me when I
was in where was I was in Summerland no
good I I was in Centennial and they
transported me to Summerlin correct and
they charged me $1,200 the bills are
insane yeah it's it's sick and I got
this first-hand experience of how
obscene the health care system is in
America I mean how much was your guy was
your bill mom well when I went to when I
went to the rheumatologist he said he
was looking through my records and he
goes well that must have been about two
million dollars Wow we don't really know
because shout out to the Affordable Care
Act because of the fact that there are
now yearly and lifetime caps on your
out-of-pocket expenses you know the most
it could have cost us what it was $8,000
instead of closer to a million which is
what it would have said well we should
without insurance
it's worth talking with okay because
like the Affordable Care Act is
something that a lot of people hate a
lot of people are talking [ __ ] oh no
everyone loves the Affordable Care Act
they don't like Obamacare which is the
same thing yeah okay but I think people
don't understand the affordable air /
Obamacare right because people just say
oh my rates are going up my rates are
going up and our rates went up a lot
like in New York we're paying $1,000 a
month right for me well the deductibles
are high and so no it's really now but
at the same but first of all getting
that down is a different conversation
but on the other hand what it does do is
it cap someone like my mom right who at
$8,000 a year max because otherwise
before that they probably would have
capped you at what I don't care did that
okay you it you would have well hey like
a percentage of it how does it work
sixty percent of personal bankruptcies
before the Affordable Care Act was from
people who were trying to pay medical
bills and declared we would have lost
our house this is the only place in the
world where people go bankrupt medical
the only industrialized country where
that can happen before before all of
this going back a few years when when
there was just you know you just had to
get insurance companies and they
wouldn't pre-existing when I had my
cancer surgery that we had to pay what
30 percent or something like that I mean
oh my god was right after Ethan was born
mom had a thyroidectomy because they
found out she had thyroid cancer which
if you're gonna get cancer is the best
one to get because it's a fairly easy
solution but once you have that you've
got to put that down so it went from
that to the only question that insurance
companies could ask is do you smoke
other than that could not ask about any
pre-existing conditions or so before you
were getting denied because of your yeah
you couldn't get insurance at all no you
could you you had access to insurance
but it cost you an arm and a leg it was
like I can't afford that much was how
much was it I got a couple thousand a
month I it wasn't expensive well we're
going back like it was 30 something
years so before the Affordable Care Act
it used to work like you would just get
the bill and then you would be liable
for like a certain percentage percent of
it which was 30 percent of a million is
still $300,000 hundred thousand dollar
bill and you're on the hook for six
hundred thousand dollars like who like
what the point yeah yeah most Americans
statistically can't put five hundred
dollars in cash together within 30 days
people our credit card debt yeah so you
know then to have to face a medical
crisis like that your grandmother and
her sister pensee had kidney problems
oh hold on one sec we have taken to
calling shoes how's the audio um you
should move your mic a little closer he
said testing one two three
that but it's not like a major breakdown
audio works okay it's fine sorry guys
sorry your your aunt who had kidney she
had kidney dialysis and all that and she
she spent her entire life paying her
bill because her her husband had just
left a job so in between jobs when he
wasn't insured is when that happened to
her and she spent the rest of their life
pain it's just mad I it's just mad I
don't know yeah I I personally believe
that health care should be it should be
a right I think so yeah I think so in
this country of Plenty when you have
people are so obscenely rich billion how
do you make a billion dollars without
[ __ ] all over the planet like
there's so much wealth it's poor people
should not have to worry about dying
first paying their bills like shameful
it's shameful and I think I think most
people would agree with that because
there's a lot of opposition a lot of
people who hate Obamacare I think they
just don't understand what it is and
what it does right I think they're
catching on now well when you ask people
you know do you support the Affordable
Care Act yeah I like that what about a
bomb go no I hate Obamacare people might
because was so politicized right it's
just like Democrats did a bad job of
telling people what it was about you
know it's easy to be against something
but to be able to actually talk about
the positives in that mm-hmm
it just you know Democrats did did a
really poor job of rolling it out it's
something that I'm grappling with myself
is like there's so much information
there's so much misinformation today
yeah you carry you how do you even sort
it like this the like we're in this age
of information and there's so much fact
some of its wrong some of its right and
and you can easily check and see what's
right or not
but there's so much being thrown at you
so far well has even the time to
fact-check this stuff it's at the point
where it's like this great paradox of
our time where it's like there's more
misinformation being spread than ever
war because it's just so overwhelming so
overwhelming so you have people talking
[ __ ] about the Affordable Care Act you
have people trying to say no this is a
good thing this is what it does it has
some flaws but is what it does and it's
like you just listen to who you trust
right and you don't have nobody has time
to check it out right but I've been
seeing a lot of like poor conservative
people who vote who supported repealing
it and now they're like oh like [ __ ] you
can I actually no actually died right
all right that's what I've seen so many
people turning up at Town Hall's for
Republican senators and congresspeople
especially in people saying I will die
if you repeal this anyway how do you you
know now that now they're working on
their secret plan the Republican
senators that they're 13 white
Republican men not telling anyone
exactly what the details are completely
hidden and then they're just gonna try
to you know pop it out and get it passed
immediately no public debate you know
when they complain that Obamacare was
rushed through well it took a year of
hearings and debate and everything
before it became before it became law
you know now they're trying to rush this
out in a couple of weeks and the Senate
version not letting anyone see at all
what they're doing so and it's very
complicated I mean things could be fixed
things could be made better but you know
it's like they want to throw the baby
out I'm sorry if they remove something
like precondition pre-existing
conditions or cat
I'm clearly raps then right like when
when when I they were debating this when
you were sick
right and right and I knew that if they
repealed it you would lose your health
insurance at like the most critical time
right and and we as a family would all
have to foot the bill like I'm not what
my choices like let you die I mean we
would be a family responsibility we were
all gonna have to it was gonna cost us
all a lot of money's for you I would
have just well what you guys can go
bankrupt I can't afford it well it's
like what let yourself die no you're
saying rather than letting us support
you my mom rather die you know yeah
let's move on we have to do a break
please there's an one update everyone
keeps asking where is so Flo cuz we said
that it was gonna wait so guys so Flo is
joining us we're working out the details
it didn't work out this week but we're
definitely booking him I think on the
30th that's why we're here where is so
far next week is Stevo you will not want
to miss that one it's gonna be amazing
and the week after that I'm working on
booking so Flo but I'll keep you guys
informed so let's take a little quick
break here we'll tell you guys about
naturebox do tell have you guys ever
heard about naturebox that's like a good
healthy snacks right naturebox.com/tyler
for /h 3 yeah so naturebox is like a
healthy snack alternative kind of thing
Kris made with good ingredients and
healthy ingredients and some dank ass
snacks is that good yeah that's good
that's very good ok so essentially it
they have over a hundred snacks I
haven't tried them yet our first ones on
the way but I want to show you guys what
they have because I'm they look
delicious
if you guys go to naturebox.com/tyler
you get three three snacks with your
first order that's free with to capital
ease snack
time and if you don't like it then
there's no risk because it's free if you
guys don't like it that's how confident
their and their snacks it looks
delicious
sure they're not here yet but I think
but like okay so this sriracha roasted
cashew looks insane I want those ones
Wow but apparently they're all like low
calorie healthy good dark cocoa good can
you put my email address in there you
might go back again and get me the money
Stamper here these milk and mayo awful
is so good but look at this [ __ ] dark
cocoa that looks good
better crisps get on board
naturebox.com/tyler get three free
flippin snacks I wish we had him here
now yeah I would snack on those but
we'll have next week if you guys want to
come oh great local guys are you kidding
me I don't know these snacks are amazing
and I've heard they're absolutely
delicious so how a pina jerky crushed
red pepper beef jerky would be interests
so head on over there and give him a
gimmick ah and I appreciate them for
supporting our shell looks delicious and
God bless Thank You naturebox
yeah Thank You nature box compost site
h3 you got links in the chat box yeah
actually um thank you to Peter and he
already put it on the dash in spam it
though if you guys are interested in
some and some healthy wholesome snacks
naturebox dot okay let's take a quick
bathroom break and we'll be back in five
minutes if you guys leave I don't want
to tell you what's gonna happen it's
gonna be real bad okay
oh it was just about I'm too slow I was
just about this family attorneys oh it
is booming um guys if you leave it's
gonna be it's gonna be really bad I
can't tell you what's gonna happen but
it's gonna regret it's gonna be sadness
and you may never see me or you again so
please don't leave we'll be back in a
short two minutes so be right back
welcome back guys to the h3 podcast here
with my parent
Diane Gary hmm and of course the legend
kleiner you guys don't suck you were
about you were just about to get into
this story before the break about the
miracle child which story I love oh that
you saw my article child yeah you saved
my life
yeah yeah tell me that story I loved it
well I thought I was pregnant and so I
went to the dead why do you have the I
know a dad's a snacker you can put on
the tape that's a good idea
don't you hate that when you go to the
movies and someone's like eating popcorn
and you can hear it you want to put on
any music videos anyway so as you were
saying well I mean you know I wasn't
feeling well and so I figured I'm
pregnant so I went to the doctor was
that a normal conclusion or were you
trying to get pregnant um no I think
with you I wanted to get pregnant Shawn
was the only like that we ever tried to
get pregnant I just wanted us not ready
and I get pregnant I swear hey what I
said I can walk us of bed and kept
pregnant
well when you have a husband who is so
incredibly masculine that you can get a
woman pregnant just by looking at her
there's a lot of Gary's there's a life's
nose Gary snows out there and Gary the
bed oh my god well somewhere the truth
is somewhere in the middle there right
well it's not a big story I just I went
to the doctor because I thought I was
pregnant and if I hadn't gone to the
doctor I would never have known that I
had thyroid cancer because I was I had
cancer when you I was pregnant with you
but you were pregnant I was pregnant but
also I've cancer but I was sick from
the cancer and I thought I was pregnant
one of those I thought I had but again
to prove the point mom is a horrible
storyteller
we win her ob/gyn and he found a lump
there and he thought that it would
endanger the child then he recommended
maybe you don't want to go spring it
would mean Ethan wouldn't be sitting
here are entertaining all of this doctor
suggested aborting yeah he did I was
like five months four months pregnant
with you any five months yeah and he
said to me how long have you had been
year three so you knew you were pregnant
so big I went to the doctor because I
wasn't feeling well and he said to me
how long have you had this lump in your
throat and I said what lump and that's
when I was going through all these tests
and it wasn't until I was four or five
months pregnant with you that they
realized I had cancer okay and and so
almost slow-moving cancer yeah that's
the one Iran yeah that was it slow one
two
so my wonderful mother Eileen Klein
liner yeah you know knows everybody
schmooze is she was our own losing new
is my cousin Sheila who is a doctor
she's her doctor degrees in nursing and
she was the one that said you have to
find that you have to go to this
particular doctor all right dr. Katz at
cedars-sinai who's probably now deceased
because he's a legend though I've heard
that Mandy was the head of one of the
top oncologists in the country and we
went to see him and sat in his office
and Donna told him what had happened
that this doctor told her oh gee you
might have to lose the baby and this was
after even no no you were still pregnant
I was like massacre we're tied to the
other doctor and you know how doctors
hate to criticize each other dr. Katz
with us sitting there in his office
called us at their doctor and chewed him
out and how
who you scared this woman you know after
identifying himself as one of the top
oncologists now he knew who he was when
he called outside eye and said you know
what kind of doctor are you how can you
scare this woman and he kind of adopted
mom as his you know wonderful relation
yeah he was great you guys say his name
yeah dr. Katz he was literally so
without him
Ethan might not be here so after you
gave birth to Ethan
the minute I gave birth to Ethan it was
like maybe two weeks I had to go in for
surgery yeah yeah so what they do is
they give you a radioactive isotope
which searches out the thyroid any
thyroid that may be left after they
remove it and just kills it but you're
radioactive
yep getting close to the children I
couldn't even go see her for a couple
days afterwards solitaire you're really
yeah you're in solitary they came out it
with a get with a Geiger counter ha ha
they did they were in spaces so you
everything was under quarantine for how
long for a week in the hospital and then
I couldn't go home for another week and
Grandma and came her know me was your
mother it might have been your mother
what came yeah most likely your mother
friends because no because I was staying
with at my parents house and my mother
was taking care of me
and I think your mom came out and took
care of you and the doctor let me you
didn't go on a bottle until you were 7
months old he let me wait a now he let
me wait to you before I had to take
radiates that's the best food right
there Mother's Milk Duds
no I I I breastfed all three of you in
Sean was still 9 months without Caitlyn
last week we were talking about you just
hey now I'm from breastfeeding in
general I know
anyway looks like who's a Caitlyn sister
who was breastfeeding her son and Game
of Thrones of kids like 10 years old in
he's oh that was great Florence but she
likes me fine hey is this youtuber with
like how old is her son by now I don't
know like four maybe don't tell me he's
still breastfeed Oh unlike she
homeschools him yeah and then she can
make big English he never learned he's
like it seems like it doesn't she want
to breastfeed and she's like forcing him
so this story is just crazy so we made a
video about this girl like years years
ago because she made these videos about
ant doing enemas and it was just a
really obscene video that we made fun of
and I've been following this girl I
haven't made a video better cuz it's too
sad too real but she's been
breastfeeding her kid and putting videos
on YouTube since she was born those four
or five years ago and she people were
calling Child Protective Services so she
actually moved to South America to
continue while hiding her kid I mean I
don't know if she says that that's the
reason that's what happened Wow and then
like um she does it I have a feeling
it's like a weird fetish thing because
she like goes out in public and
breastfeed and does it in like really
public places and the bit end like
they're such shots were like she shows
her close up and he's like not lashing
milk the odds that this boy will grow up
well-adjusted zero point zero that kids
bro I mean that kids probably gonna eat
someone like that's I think it's that
bad he's gonna eat somebody not in a
good night yeah he's like he's gonna
like probably have sex and eat someone's
penis I don't know I'm like thinking
like what's the weirdest sex people get
right he's gonna Ramsay Bolton he's
gonna actually have you been watching
Game of Thrones we just came across the
rainbow we just watched that episode
where it looked like he was eating Theon
Greyjoy's wiener but actually was a
sausage you said that's weird
it's
it's too weird sandwich I don't like
going down that rabbit hole makes me
uncomfortable it's not she's a vegan
let's keep talking about it like she's
forcing her newborn baby to be vegan
that's enough that's good
she's working her newborn baby to be
vegan well when your newborn all you
have is is well you could what I
remember okay she made a video where he
had a yep what was it called yellow
fever some [ __ ] is that a real thing
yellow fever yeah so she was saying he
has yellow fever and the best antidote
is tit milk she's like he doesn't need
medicine he just needs to suck on my tit
and she kept trying to breastfeed me how
old how old was the baby's like 5 is not
babies ah because because in before a
mother's milk comes in you get this
clear stuff it's and it's filled with
antibodies and that's what that's why I
dress being so I don't think there's any
antibodies love no there's not it
they're just bodies yeah so this video
surfaced of her that's kind of sick Dan
is saying that the chewing oh the
chewing dad what do you come on I'm
chewing tobacco come on dude oh we don't
cancer in we're done with cancer but
then the same girl something for like we
always we always figured it was some
weird fetish thing but we never had
proof right so then a video surface of
her she was has takes videos of herself
having sex with the cucumbers straw for
me where I was like damn this [ __ ] got
weird yeah are the cucumbers condoms or
is this just it's all mere belle-isle
bareback organic they're as true if it's
organic cucumbers I can see that non-gmo
Wow non GMO non condom where can you
find these
I'm scary yeah let's make a clean cut
and now for something completely
different as Monty Python would say so
anyway um you guys know anyone else
that's cancer yeah my my best friend
Vicki she's still moving right along
cancer in the rear view okay I wish her
the best
she's better better she's gonna be fine
which is great yeah let's take a 180
turn okay off that but I wish for the
best ghost story okay so for some reason
the subject of ghost stories always
comes up on a podcast it's a really
interesting topic for us all to talk
about my mom my mom looks very excited
right now something you have something
to share this so my question is I'll
start with you mom do you have any ghost
stories um no but like so excited
because I burned a present I might play
into that somehow oh so you don't have
any ghost stories um I would have body
experience but that's not it that's not
a ghost it's supernatural how do you
explain that go I don't know no I
explained it was here okay so this was a
long long time it how long ago b:g
before Gary no nothing's that long
nothing that old now but I I was I don't
know if I should tell this story I don't
know before saying the gained under
Mike's is too much too much again yeah
what does that mean it's too loud it's
like tearing we have a problem with the
sound Dan okay guys we'll fix than that
if you say I don't know if I should tell
this story the answer is no you
shouldn't okay no no okay I don't mean
drug-related no tell me about it let's
hear it
this is what this is the produced this
is why we come together this is
interesting it's wrong you seem worried
weird I don't know if I should say love
love love love like her head no I want
to hear it come on you cannot no well no
I have no idea where she's going that's
why I'm scared whisper in Dad's yeah I
know I know know this so the sound is
fine I don't think it sounds back okay
then we haven't even know need this Thor
this is dangerous
come on how dangers can be told it could
be really dangerous can I tell you off
the air yeah sure everyone listening
would love to hear you tell it off the
air no you're committed now bring it
okay alright I'll hear it do you want to
write it first for someone she was ready
to end in me filing for divorce papers
or no your father and I have been
married for 42 years 42 years Wow 42
years seems like a long time yes and and
all marriages have ups and downs there's
no such perfect marriage and we got
married when we were young and and there
was a time in our relationship where we
broke up for a little bit I don't know
if you remember that I mean I know like
way before you were born are you playing
stuff no I'm not so anyway so this was a
time in my life a short time when I was
with another person and I was widely in
bed together you blew it yeah I wonder I
never heard this story I was I was
actually in bed and this other person
was sleeping and I was I was up at least
I thought I was up maybe I was sleeping
and I just remember I I was somehow I
was like flying
and I was looking down on myself and
this other person and I thought for a
minute that this was really cool that I
was flying and then I got scared
and yeah I got scared and then I
remember I took my hand and I tried to
grab myself to hold on to not like fly
away from my body and my hand went
through my body and I thought oh my god
am i dead what's happening and then at
the last minute when I realized that
maybe this is not a good thing it may be
this isn't a dream maybe something
Horrible's happen to me
I screamed out your father's name I did
I swear to God I screamed out your name
because I wanted I wanted you and I
think we got back together let's talk
about how much fun I had never do you
think maybe it could be like a sleep
paralysis thing maybe maybe I don't know
I mean I I mean it couldn't have been
real I couldn't have been flying but it
seems so real good I was blind I was
looking down on myself and I and I
wanted a night you were awake maybe
you're a la I thought it was awake maybe
you're a warg
so that was my weird end I woke up I was
screaming for dad's name and then I woke
up you're not the first woman to do that
okay white one thing happened to me that
was really weird this is when your
sister was a little baby she was like
maybe four well not a little baby just
maybe like four yeah baby this is before
both you and your brother were born and
I remember I was having a weird dream a
monster dream and
it was freaking me out and I woke up and
Jessica came into the room and she's she
said mom I'm having this monster dream
and she she wanted to like crawl into
bed with us for security because she was
having a say it was the same dream that
I was having the same dream the same
dream that's bizarre
that was really spoke about that like oh
all the time
huh all the time we both made I mean it
was something we remembered that's
really weird yeah and I woke up when she
came into my room and told me that she
was having this monster dream so that's
that's about all did you have any
monster energy drink that night by any
chance no I don't think they had this
all right I'm just asking Dead have
given any ghost stories no not you're
like me you're very I feel like you're
very empirical yeah I've just had my
weird dream stories like mom - like why
would the movie poster and wait it's
really interesting and I see the effect
it had on you yeah it's well I was you
know my my wonderful mother Eileen was
way ahead of her time she got married
very young married her high school
sweetheart who uncle was in the movie
industry his uncle my my biological
father's Leonard Katzman his his uncle
was Leonard Sam Katzman who was the king
of B movies so my mother though was
divorced when I was about four four and
a half or so so he became a single mom
divorced work and you know and no one
did that back in the 50s and you know my
father worked for his uncle on doing
movies he ended up going to a lot of
fame and fortune he wrote who shot
junior anyone who knows Dallas he wrote
and produced you know all of the famous
Dallas show so he had tremendous amount
of success and I was actually in a movie
because he was big
of his uncle he was shooting movie
called the magic carpet which was in
probably 1951 and installed Lucille Ball
and Raymond Burr and all these people
who no one knew who they were back then
and they needed a baby to be laid on a
Magikarp and fly out the window and grow
into someone else who had a baby well
Lennie Katzman had a baby which was me
so I was on the magic carpet I flew out
the window I came up and I came back I'm
John agar who knows even knows now who I
would never have cast to grow up as me
but so I knew that there was a poster or
something about this movie but it was so
small you never heard anything about it
it's never on TV anymore but there's a
small-time movie very small-time movie
right Sam Katzman B movies 1951 find it
on IMDB doesn't even have a page it
exists and I always look forward on TV
just to see if I was in it and there's a
tremendous a company called Heritage
Auctions and they do movie poster
auctions and collectibles and I think
they're one of the biggest auction
companies in the country so I put a
search in for them for the magic carpet
the movie I was in
and this was I mean really almost as
soon as the internet started going in
heritage ACOs exist right probably 15
years ago at least and it was there was
there nothing nothing nothing in about
six seven months ago I had the oddest
dream because I you know I was legally
adopted by Mike Kline the wonderful man
who raised me took me as his own child
legally adopted so I gave up the Katzman
name never you know really even thought
had a dream had any concepts about you
know what Lenny was doing aside from
Dallas and and all that stuff but about
six seven months ago I had a really odd
dream where I was kind of like a fly on
a wall kind of ethereal spirit floating
around and I could see a guy who I knew
was my father Leonard Katzman standing
in front of a movie theater pointing at
the you know the windows they have in
front with the posters of the movies
there and he was standing with a bunch
of his friends standing
they're talking to them pointing at it
no I couldn't
you know actually hear what they were
saying but I knew as clearly as I'm
sitting here looking at you I knew
exactly what was going that it was my
father and he was talking to his friends
saying look this is me this is the first
movie I've looked at you know it's
pretty cool right and and I woke up
after that and it was just very profound
you know the fact I had dreamt about my
biological father why he'd never ever
had a dream about before did you ever
meet him yeah I did um let me let's go
back to that remind me of that um so you
know I woke up and I told mom's like wow
I had the weirdest dream you know I I I
was up in the air floating and I saw my
biological father do you know talking
about this and and of course mom didn't
remember when I came to her later and
which was very disappointing but anyway
so about three weeks a month after
having this really weird dream I get a
notice from Heritage Auctions after 15
years the magic carpet movie poster is
now available and you've been looking
for it oh you're lying fifteen years I'd
had a you know a search up for that and
how long between that this was like two
weeks after I had had that weird dream
of him of my father pointing at this
poster right so just you know the odds
of those things being not connected
really well just seemed very weird and
again I you know like you I'm very
empirical and very scientific I don't
believe it
mumbo-jumbo but I believe in just you
know the the odds of that happening were
just it just seems so weird that you
know I believe in the strange
contradiction that you you control what
happens in your life but certain things
are destined are fated to happen which
is a total oxymoron but that's what I
believe I believe I was destined to meet
your mother you know certain things just
happen in life now of course your
brother will argue till he can't talk
anymore but to have that dream and then
a couple weeks later after 15 years to
have that movie poster up
is really really bizarre I don't wanna
leave in coincidences and that was
genomic winds yes so now I have that
movie Bush right Felicia bought it with
me I bought it free
yeah Lana and and what you know so it
came up for auction so I bid on it like
twenty five thirty dollars and someone
bid against me and it's like dude I
don't know I have a dream Doug yeah
everyone else in this movie is dead so I
know you have no connection cuz I was
only six months old when this movie was
made so you know maybe some people are
alive but you know no one has any
interest this thing dog I'm winning this
poster I don't care how much it feels
how high did it get and I'd end up only
costing me like 50 bucks or something he
wasn't that invested yeah exactly yeah
so I haven't I haven't gotten it framed
yeah yeah we need to get a frame but
yeah it's pretty cool it was nice to
have that after thinking about it for so
long what do you make of that I mean
what's your what's your feeling on that
do you feel like coincidence or just no
like I mean do you feel like it has
something to do with like your dad from
beyond the grave or something just like
cosmic I don't think so I'm going back
to the question did I ever meet him your
mother after Jessica was born
I called called Lennie my biological
father and yelled at him for not being
there even though he didn't your mom
from the hospital called him up and
yelled at it for not being there when
his first grandchild was born even
though he had no idea that his one who
was born Jessica Graham sister yeah I
heard heard about about Leonard right
everyone knew of him because of his fame
now in Dallas and everything going on
anyways I was just I was just dad told
me that a story when he was a little boy
and his father left the house for the
last time and he's do you want to tell
the story well yeah that was the last
when we finally got together after years
and years have finally worked up the
nerve to call him he was working at MGM
studios in Culver City and Dallas was
going strong
and I finally called them up and this
was probably in the mid-80s I would
think and you know cut ran through his
office and they went who is this and
when it's Gary Klein and Leonard son so
I got through I talked to him we got
together I went down to MGM studios
unless have been surreal it was it was
very weird it was kind of like strangely
awkward I can my I can imagine I mean
it's not it's no one's fault it's like
right just out of the blue I thought it
was someone's fault so that well clearly
well I
okay look and and you can't really
relate moment I mean what can you do
right and you can't really relate to
this to you're a parent and you realize
what it's like to give up a child but
his last memory of me was you know me as
a four-year-old child standing in the
driveway as he's driving off for the
last time saying daddy daddy where are
you going that's hard which yeah exactly
has to really tear you apart right but
at the same time he didn't it I like
well at the request of the of the father
who adopted me thought everyone thought
it would be better if I just grew up
with one father rather they did to do
that how do you feel about them making
that decision for you now in retrospect
it's tough especially knowing how rich
and famous my by what kind of pissed me
off an actress back that's [ __ ] up
that's doesn't seem right to not to
block you out from your viologic well
but that's what you did then you know
and and looking back on it you know what
what's the father that adopted me took
on was the fact you know this woman had
been with another man he had a son who
had already been influenced by this guy
and to take me on and raised me as his
own son you know completely the same as
my brother and sister and the families
ended up I ended up with a half-brother
and half-sister with my new family and
my biological father remarried a woman
who brought an older son into the
marriage just like my mom did and then
they had a girl and a boy so they were
like shadow families of exactly the same
family that that my family had and then
yeah so so anyways what
dad told me the story about you know how
his dad left and and and of course being
a modern woman thinking you know what is
this you give up your your child no no
it doesn't work that way that's my
thinking well now it seems insane to me
now but I guess I mean you know it seems
totally I mean now these days it's like
what right had a new dad
[ __ ] off it's right exactly so so I when
when Jessica was born I called up Lenny
he just came in from being in Hawaii
yeah I was macking on Hawaii five-o
wrangly did wild wild west and right
five-o and a whole chain of right so and
I I just said I explained to him who I
was and that he was a grandfather and he
dropped the [ __ ] it was like so freaked
out but he dropped the phone yeah call
he hung up on you no no no he was like
drop the phone and then he picked it up
he was just like so what died you know
he's like oh I mean I just said I I'm
not asking for anything I just wanted
you to know your grandfather you ever
come no no huh no and and and did he
ever show interest in being involved not
really no I think yeah I feel like I
think that ship had sailed at that point
yeah you know but not at that but I mean
like when you were growing up cuz I feel
like maybe back then well you know was
one way but still probably the dad would
have some curiosity yeah well well
especially your feeling on that you know
I mean if he had just been some schlub
it probably wouldn't matter but the fact
he was they went under such success and
that he had two adopted well one natural
and one adopted son who worked on the
show and I would see there an assistant
director and credits and then when I
found out that Mitchell my my half
brother who is another weird story how I
met him you know worked on the show was
an assistant director and ended up being
the boyfriend of Victoria Principal for
six months or so who was back in the day
who was almost as beautiful as your
mother you know and live with her is his
girlfriend but there's good
there's good and bad what were you
saying that just the fact that like he
was missing all that yeah but there for
the sake of God goes I yeah you know so
that that should have been me you know
that was my thinking not counting you
you were you were sad it yeah yeah
jealous essentially exactly you were
jealous yeah that's kind of a real thing
to acknowledge you know I feel like that
would that would like is a underneath
emotion that would take time to realize
yeah cuz I grew up as a you know middle
class you know we did okay we grew up in
a great area and I had great friends but
when you look at what you could have
been oh I could have been rich I could
have been successful it did but you know
after meeting my brother and finding out
what he went through and knowing my
addictive personality you know back in
that time I would kill myself with a
od'd on cocaine would had done something
like that where you know what we
wouldn't have gotten at this point
because I've said many a time the best
thing that ever happened to me was
meeting this incredible woman right here
and that's been the blessing in my life
that's led to everything else so that's
what you think you forget it but like
it's I find that really interesting like
so after all these years you've do you
think that you found peace with that
after seeing kind of like imagining
maybe that your life wouldn't have been
as good it would have been more [ __ ]
up messed up or had you had he never
left or you know yeah it would have been
interesting to try you know we all know
alternate universe right he had the big
beautiful house on the beach in Malibu
and all of the things you know he really
had the best part of success which is
the money and the power without the fame
so he could go anywhere he wanted no one
would recognize him up until the who
shot jr. and he had his picture in
People magazine or whatever you know no
one knew who he was
so he could go crazy spend a lot of
money and you know and have all the
success but money does not buy happiness
most definitely not that's true but as
David Lee Roth said sure money doesn't
buy happiness but you can buy a big old
cabin cruiser and cruise up that close
to it
yeah you know money doesn't hurt that's
for sure so well yeah that's a find the
whole thing interesting I find it so
interesting like I feel this way with
you guys I imagine that everyone feels
this way about their parents to some
degree but it's like there's these
people that you spend your whole life
well you spend more time with your
parents than almost anyone
you know and there's just so much you
don't know about them like how
frequently do sit down and just have
like a conversation where you just talk
about [ __ ] like the fact that you were
adopted and all these details and stuff
is something that we hardly ever spoke
about but it's um when I spend my whole
life with that comedy time it's just
it's it's like a weird father-son are
just you know parent relationship is
very interesting I don't know why that
is why don't you talk about why don't
you talk about that stuff with your
parents it's weird we talked about I
don't know not I mean generally no not
that much yeah I guess it's probably
because you're you're they look so
familiar right and you're so moving on
to you know differently yeah it's you
know we're not peers or maybe up until
now we're not peers but like only until
like the age of when I cannot have my
own job recording myself can I sit down
across the table from you guys and be
like we're peers right like I can talk
to you guys about your life and stuff a
lot at this point I'm happy you consider
me a peer you know what I mean I do
raise your kids in the best way that you
that you know how well as you find out
when you become a parent that you know
when you're a kid you grew up thinking
wow my parents know everything they're
so smart realize you don't know what
you're doing and that your parents
didn't know what the [ __ ] they were
doing but everything ends up okay
somehow you muddle through you call them
once in a while to get advice but yeah
as an example let me look at these two
great kids they can be really good
people so we did something right yeah
yes
he was parents you know it's a weird
wild stuff parents huh what are you
doing again live with them you can't
live without him all right literally all
right let's take another commercial
break here okay we got another sponsor
here we got three sponsors yes so blast
last week we spoke about me undies not
last week but previously previously me
undies is this really wonderful
underwear company modal how's that
called yeah modal's like the have you
guys ever felt modal I have not I would
love that's the underwear that I wanted
to get that's gonna be a disgusting mess
anyway anyway feel that material it's
like so if you guys nice and soft
if you guys go to meet undies com4 / h3
you can get 20% off your first pair plus
free shipping last time I hadn't tried
them on
so actually plot twist I'm wearing them
right now
TMI TMI it's like it's so it's just
underwear Gary that it's not a Rubik's
Cube it's a piece on me like a no that's
a fear of guy it's yeah women don't have
a penis to take out here now you tell me
that's got a surprise I knew something
was missing
it's so soft and it breathes like crazy
it's it's seriously that I think the
best pair of underwear like I usually
don't wear briefs but it's like it's
very comfortable very nice it's so soft
I think men should wear briefs I mean
we're I'm a boxer guy I you ya guys are
Bob briefs are just they're tight and
they get annoying and they like chafe my
fat pear-shaped disgusting body where it
used to be the Fupa still less Fupa but
these with the me undies in the Safa
middle it breathe I'll hook you guys up
a pair so the last time we did a me
undies spot they had this hilarious
thing where if you didn't like it you
send back the undies like they were
sorting out dirty undies about their I
mean it's a nice deal right they refund
your money but now they're kicking it up
a notch I guess they heard our spot and
they're like maybe they got too many
dirty on do ship to them more like you
know what yeah I think one day they
probably have a furnace where they just
throw it off so now if you don't love
your first pair of me undies they're
free you get to keep your dirty hug
that's a great deal so that's that's
smart guys if you want some baingan on
DS go to Mandy's comm for such h3 they
support the show thank you guys so much
spam it in the description alright thank
you guys and then we'll do one more here
well we got you guys and then we'll just
continue on
hey you guys done you feeling okay
Wow sometimes I cough so intensely
smiths brothers cough drops is in our
next spot no that's no sponsor this show
but I would love if there's any cough
drop puppies out there that would be a
perfect match up next up you guys know
him you love them Dollar Shave Club have
you guys seen this tell their shave club
yes I have I've seen it I'm not seeing
it at your house I want to get some
stuff I got so much you know yeah I
actually do disabled love that stuff
like so Dollar Shave Club has been like
so supportive of us like we make on the
most controversial messed up videos
they'll they'll put their [ __ ] on there
and support us they're like god bless
you you know this is why I love Dollar
Shave Club and I mean the product is
amazing so this blade is hefty boy
that's a strong have you feel it feel
the way nice is it a double double tri
quadruple gnarly what's more than
quadruple ones f five or five six
septuple I believe it really Wow so
comes with four four these septuple
blades its these lasts a while too like
yeah you get you get for these and you
get the shave butter and the razor and
the post cream for five dollars
I know it's called Dollar Shave Club
okay we got some kickback yes it's
called Dollar Shave Club you get that
for the razors I'm talking about shaved
butter cream extra cartridges it's a
really good product for five bucks
that's ridiculous so let's gotta hate
these guys seriously I mean you go to
the grocery store how much are raises
like 20 bucks really the rent
yeah the whole there's nothing but they
kill you on the blade look at scheme if
you go to Costco like they have the
blades on a board they don't even have
the blades and people steal a high value
so $5.00 for this is honestly agree
agree right I personally endorse this I
use it it's the only blade that doesn't
give me a razor burn I mean just
something like the shea butter would be
five bucks it yeah so guys Father's Day
is right around the corner
dollarshaveclub.com for /h three five
dollars gets you an amazing Father's Day
present in fact I got an idea for
Father's Day okay I'm gonna get you some
there you got a shaved Club shout-out to
Father's Day
finally a worthwhile holiday anyway I
honestly can't endorse this this product
enough so if you guys are in the market
for some razors think people spend so
much money on that oh yeah just get out
there five bucks forget about it
how often can you reorder what's like
when you I think it's a monthly it's a
month I'm not actually I can't be
actually I think it may be is fifteen
the second month okay but the first
month is five dollars that's not even
exclusive offer did so that's the deal
you get five bucks go to
dollarshaveclub.com ford slash h3 for
your hot hot hot place and I and I love
all of our sponsors you guys these these
are the best they these guys make the
show possible so if you can't support
them if you hear a product that you like
and you want to support the show get
involved pick it up we appreciate that
correctly you said afterwards it's nine
yeah wow that's not this that's so good
it's so first month this five if you use
our if you use our URL and after that's
ten a month cool thank you everybody
thank did you spam that [ __ ] spam it boy
are you cool alright well um thanks for
sponsors let's do you guys want to take
a quick bathroom break and come back and
like I wanna give a quick shout out to a
very polite and friendly young man that
came up and said hi Vegas cane wal Mac
ah a fan of h3h3 came up to us attained
walnut are you Ethan's mom and dad and
myself gets recognized all the time but
it really was the first time well you
mom's been a superstar shining part of
the history lore for a while so yeah
very polite like all God
interaction they are just the greatest
friendliest nicest hikers yeah really
thank you Kane and you know all of the
h3 fans you guys are fantastic oh yeah
and I agree oh good work they're
fantastic every I mean they're super
nice I've only had one bad interaction
but he wasn't a fan he was just thankful
I have interesting I want to tell that
story but I also want to ask you
something like tying into that story
about your dad
mm-hmm do you feel like how does it feel
now because you your dad was famous
I'm not faint I'm not famous on his
level but do you feel like some weird
thing about now you're getting
recognized because of your son like is
that a weird tie-in to more because
she's been in more videos I've had
people it'll be more I won't be able to
walk to my car exactly as you you had
this you probably less as I understand
it you in your bloody you're excited
about it right you you dreamed about
being recognized and being famous about
a big movie since I was six months off
but do you feel like in a weird way
you're getting that fulfilled when
someone recognize you on the street not
really it just makes me proud of what
you've accomplished here starting from
nothing and you know you guys have just
made something incredible yeah this so
it just makes me feel bright it's fun
I went to UM Starbucks right where you
know we're used to work or were you okay
still stir anyways
free coffee please can we get some
coffee out here and just some young man
behind the counter looked up at me when
I was ordering my iced tea and
recognized me and asked you know to take
a picture with me nobody I got my I got
my ice tea lickety-split he's got over
there yeah it is weird being be
recognized is surreal it takes some time
to adjust to it it just happened to me
when I
my mom is visiting here and also my
brother we lived in New York right now
he also came here so we were all walking
downtown LA and some guy recognized me
and so it's funny because it's it's
almost like you just know each other
sometimes people will just be like hey
what up and it's almost like so my
brother and my mom we're like this is so
weird they like it's like you walk
around and some people just know you
like your friends or something well
sometimes people approach you too and
they'd be like hey what up and you don't
know if it's like do you know me from
the internet or have we met somewhere
right or sometimes people will just like
stare at you with like a familiarity in
their eye and you don't know if it's
like we do you recognize me or what's
happening like there's some interesting
encounters that as a result I remember
when we were when we were like the three
of us and and Ella was with us that one
time when we went to Ikea connect and
that young man kept on walking back and
forth and then he yeah a long time ago
when we were yeah that happens where
people are like don't happen they don't
want to disturb us or they're like
embarrassed and then so like I'll notice
them like pacing back and forth like
that's sweet though yeah well when I was
with Sean this was in Studio City we
were having breakfast and out of the
corner of my eye I see this young man
sitting in a booth that's like almost as
close as I am to you maybe a little
further away and I looked at me he looks
so familiar he had a hat on and he had a
full beard and I looked over and I
looked at him like do I know you and
then I realized it was Adam Levine uh
yeah he was with his his wife right and
and I looked him and then all of a
sudden it must have been a look of
recognition on my face like no you go
and he smiled at me which I thought was
really sweet yeah he's way more famous
than we are yeah but I mean it's kinda
like a you know he people recognize
what's interesting you I think that
famous people have to deal with you know
at the at the bike shop I owned a bike
shop for 25 years in beautiful Ventura
California
because we're close to Ojai I had quite
a few celebrity clients including the
late great Bill Paxton who was just a
really great guy man rest in peace
that's a shame but great guy he bought
ton of bikes from me he actually bought
the Schwinn phantom the same bike I had
so when he came in I could see him deal
with that look of recognition that
people gave him him and here knowing
that but not want to sit you've got to
live your life exactly and just kind of
going guy and he just handled it so
wonderfully he was just a yeah really
good you I rest in peace bill
so it's interesting you know it's
something you know and it's the kind of
the double-edged sword of Fame and
you're kind of dealing with that too you
know people that go into the industry
want to become famous they want to
become known and then when you do is
like oh I can't go anywhere without
people bothering like there's a lot of
drawbacks to it well yeah I mean
obviously it comes with territory like
we were just watching this clip of Jerry
Seinfeld someone was asking how do you
deal with being famous and being
approached by fans things like it's part
of the job yeah as far as the job you
can't go out and expect to be like you
know famous entertainer or a popular
entertainer or not deal with like the
side effects you can't have both we went
to e3 recently which is like a the
biggest video game convention in the
world and it comes to LA every year and
we've never been to a convention for so
yes was it yesterday the day before the
day before yesterday we got tickets to
go to the show and we had like an hour
left hour and a half left and like we
got we were getting stopped so much it
was just out of school and then when
once person would stop us then like a
whole group would form it turned into
like a fan meetup where we know we
didn't even get inside the building
oh because we were getting I guess
there's like it's usually not that bad
but I think that's like a perfect
overlap yeah it's it's exactly our
audience the people yo they're like
being in Sweden this is like a perfect
overlap they're like internet culture
right which is where were the most
popular but like it was just every step
you know we were getting stopped and
we're trying to meet our friend inside
and he's waiting for us and we just we
never made
it in oh and it's like you don't want to
be rude I gotta go I'm sorry but they're
like like - can I please please get a
picture and everyone's got a story of
like man I love your videos they text
your friend to let him know you were
stayin so it's like you know on one hand
I appreciate these people so much so
this is why we stopped and took we took
food with everyone yeah you can't really
complain about that I'm not no of course
I'm not complaining but you just have to
expect yeah you have to like accept it
that surprised me that's the first time
that we have been kind of like hey from
doing something it's it felt kind of
like a suicide because we just walked in
and then it was like I mean what have we
done like we couldn't really we need a
disguise it again yes a lot of people do
they get disguises I have a funny funny
celebrity story and it has to do with
with dads mom I went out to a deli with
with his sister and his mom and I don't
mean not even Paula my sit Mar your aunt
and we're having lunch at the deli and
Mel Brooks and a bunch of other yeah a
bunch of other really famous writers
comedians are in the booth next to me
and us and your mutton your grandmother
Eileen looks over and sees Mel Brooks
and she says I thought that was so funny
well I know cuz he could have just like
blew her off but he was so funny you
know I thought that was great well that
was your first interaction with Mel
Brooks and then oh yeah you have more
but yeah yeah Mel Brooks is like the
old-timey like yeah he's like perfectly
grandmas era yeah he was with his wife
and that bedding when we one of the
great comics one of the great writers
Blazing Saddles Get Smart
so many great things when mom and I were
in Paris throwing that just happened to
be where my University of Paris teacher
we were at the door say Museum which is
just an amazing Museum of Van Gogh is in
just the most you know mom and I love
art so we can spend hours and hours in
there it's an old it's an old trains
train station and there's a big giant
claw
and a lot of people take pictures there
right and outside of the cafe where the
clock is there's like a balcony and look
over Paris and we we go out there and
there's Mel Brooks standing there just
looking over everything and his wife
Annette I didn't see in Bancroft no she
thought I said to mom what do you think
of this idea I'm gonna go up to Mel
Brooks pretend I don't know who he is
and say oh you're an American could you
take a picture of which right that seems
like yeah that would be fun yeah I'm
saying no no don't bother him you know
leave him alone so it's a great idea
thank you she talked me out of mother he
knows he knows you know
Mel's melp shout out to Mel he knows you
know oh you're a funny guy would you
like a job as a writer that's how all
these fantasies play out you're the
funniest person I've ever met
yeah we're gonna be partners um people
are really curious about your bed fan
story oh one bad fan story we've had
hundreds at this point they've all been
amazing this one happened only one bad
one only one bad Adam said it like okay
okay we've had hundred of the poison
they've all been amazing yeah we've only
had one bad one it was in New York we
were in the Upper West Side which is the
neighborhood we lived in and we were
crossing the street to go grocery
shopping and there was a dude across the
street with he was grinning
he had like a shit-eating grin like he
was staring right at me so I assumed he
was just really happy to see me he was
probably a fan you want to say what up
pretty big guy too pretty burly dude and
so where he's at one end to the
crosswalk I'm at another turns green we
start coming towards each other
and I'm like hey Dawg what up how are
you and I like reached out my hand to
shake his hand and he big guy he [ __ ]
shoulder bumps me super hard and he goes
what's up [ __ ] and then he just walked
off he didn't even turn around and he
just walked off I was like what no it
was disturbing it was weird we're about
like Larry thinks I mean yeah smiling
except expecting him to just kind of
so is this something that recognized you
that's just a dick yeah definitely
recognized me but for some reason hater
yeah you're famous fu that's like a salt
yeah you can tell when someone
recognizes you you know you're looking
at one you um most of the time yes but
anyway I was just like what I mean I was
not I wasn't scared so much I was just
baffled yeah I was like why would you
wrong with you die like I mean he must
have been unstable like who does that
I guess who actually does that that's in
the same thing you know so I'm glad he
didn't stab me
I got great instead you I got I'm gonna
have to walk her out the best from now
on
[ __ ] yeah that [ __ ] so there's like that
other aspect
I mean imagine being John Lennon Oh God
we lived literally one block away from
where he was murdered right in front of
the Dakota yeah we got murdered on 67
right 77 oh he got murdered on 72nd we
were on 73rd Yeah right there yeah we we
went and visited you
you were right around the corner from
there we've been listening to a lot of
the Sirius XM just started a Beatles
channel which and their musics finally
more available and yeah why is that they
maybe they lessen success now people are
trying to word the Beatles term finally
get recognized yeah well the license
holders were real pricks they just were
not giving it up okay they're asking for
like billions of dollars huh Michael
Jackson or I don't know Michael Jackson
is that the weirdest thing yeah well I
think Paul bought most of his stuff back
from them but I don't know I don't know
but I remember when they did that song
what was it ivory ebony and ivory when
they did the duet that was Paul and
Michael Jackson yeah I'm because I think
you want to do a little bit of it yeah
yeah Bernie I don't know that wanna miss
much no it wasn't a great song but I
have a feeling that Paul Paul McCartney
probably wanted to be friends with him
to get his music back you think it was
just a big scam
i I I mean Michael Jackson was a pretty
you know famous interesting yeah they're
on the same level of family I'd say yeah
you know it's another topic that that I
seem to be talking about more which is
you know the time when your mother and I
grew up which was really was the sixties
was such an amazing time to grow up
especially in Southern California here
because of music and lifestyle and
culture and to have the Beatles and Led
Zeppelin and the Rolling Stones and all
of these incredible acts and the
politics and you know I almost hate to
say that you know we really grew up in
what may ultimately be looked upon as
you know the best time to to be a kid in
the United States where you know we had
hope we saw the first man land on the
moon we had President Kennedy you know
we had civil rights fights and women's
equality and so many things you know
going forward and so many social real
socials not phony social justice warrior
what's your name humungous stuff but you
know your pronouns
yeah actual things to be guess that's
true out and now kind of you know not
that the countries on the downslide but
there's just not the same optimism that
we had I completely agree I mean and I
find that whole thing interesting about
like the great the well you guys are the
baby boomers right that's your
generation a groomer I mean you guys
grew up in like the most prosperous time
yeah yeah and I feel like a lot of baby
boomers throw a lot of [ __ ] at our
generation for being lazy and not being
successful as they were Millennials
don't they seem to be I don't know if
envious is the right word of baby
boomers but I see online a lot of people
blaming baby boomers a lot of
Millennials blaming baby boomer
anything that goes wrong oh well I think
you baby boomer knows well we have we
have a way worse than you guys did as a
general when you guys criticize us as
lazy like oh well I paid myself through
college for $10 an hour and I will [ __ ]
you right like I like how much money do
we spend on my college like a hundred
thousand bucks at ten dollars a night
you can you know get me
thousand I think and then I spent 22
right yeah your fifth year my I get
blame for that right but I'm saying we
laid the rules down like looking at the
statistic ruse the same expenses at the
same price but they're going crazy they
want us to talk about when fans come to
our house oh god okay house fan house so
yeah we do have some weird fan
interactions at our house they haven't
been bad it's just weird cuz it's like
don't come to my house is my private
space that you would think should I have
to explain it right to you sometimes
like the first time it happened happened
like a week after we moved in it was not
really creepy because we were so careful
to not disclose that we're showing
identifying area and these guys these
kids show up and they're and at first I
don't answer the door but I'm like okay
let me confront this I want to know how
did they find out where we live and so I
go out there and they're nice guys I
think they just whatever they're fans
there I don't know they just don't Mabel
or autism I don't know to be honest like
how they're if they seem like good
people they just don't they don't think
about it but that's what they don't see
the whole picture yeah there needs to be
a line there regardless they weren't
mean-spirited they were very kind they
brought us a gift which I'll get into
that later it's a funny story but
regardless I was like how did you guys
find it find our house and they're like
you showed a sliver of the hillside
through the bathroom in your last video
Wow I'm not sure I believe them yeah I
don't know because I went back and
watched that video and it's literally
like a tiny size like some trees you
know so if they live there no it's
possible but more likely I think they
followed us home from harm
okay I know next staked out the
neighborhood and it happened another
time and that's what the guy pretty much
admitted that that's what they did -
yeah the fine thing about that story was
they came and they dropped off a bottle
of Pepsi Max and a $20 gift card - or no
it was a fifty dollar card to rouse and
a 25 dollar gift card to Papa John's
and that's that guys I appreciate you
coming out here but it's not cool please
you got to respect our boundaries but
it's really nice to meet you and I kind
of like scold them a little bit and
immediately the minute after they left
we went straight to Ralph's spend every
single penny on that went to my friend's
house or Papa John's Pizza how's he
gonna behave if they could like track
that online and see that I spent it like
immediately we're literally out the door
to go to our friends house like I
probably spent it on like the scope of
30 minutes yeah
is that where we've the money we spent
on that great Ralph's dinner last night
I was chicken and everything all for you
where we that made for I haven't been
the same since them you know last time
my dad was here we went to Ralph's at
3:00 a.m. we bought Fried Chicken okay
whatever it was what are you in trouble
what do you have two moms grounding you
she's grabbing you dude okay so anyway
about Fried Chicken tequila and like
tequila some other horrible salsa chips
so like I have in digestion I have asked
reflux I have a problem and since that
day I I think I got a ulcer in my neck
like I was so [ __ ]
I couldn't eat normal food for like a
full month and I haven't recovered from
that day really think jacked dude
tequila night chicken watch out that
night I have one last topic going and
let me just answer the other question
they keep asking if I have a bad fence
story well we also we our stories are
the same just understand me always so
that at that time that even was talking
about I was also there and it was pretty
uncomfortable but other than that
nothing bad everyone's nice yeah I'm
good yeah house is a little awkward
we just don't answer the door anymore
like yeah we have a can swing the door
we have a camera outside our house so if
you come to our house and you're a fan
we don't recognize you we just don't we
don't
package they're gonna leave itself just
not opening the door yeah we don't know
you need like a nice pet like a direwolf
a direwolf helpful great good suggestion
thank you
so I find this interesting I don't know
why but I know you guys children of the
70s right or 66 when was it that acid
hit the scene almost like the acid test
that was early seventies flower power
now 60s mid sixties Timothy Leary
started at Harvard with the acid
experimentation Baba Ram Dass beer now
we've talked about a little bit but yeah
that like the the summer of 67 68 was
the Summer of Love and that's when all
the psychedelic stuff really started you
guys were there Ground Zero right well
San Francisco really was ground zero but
LA was you know Changa canyon and all
that stuff you know was very popular too
so yeah yeah I heard you guys had some
wild what do you guys must have some
wild stories from those days yeah yeah
like going on the theme of like never
sitting across from your parents and
actually like hearing like who they are
what they've been through them with this
[ __ ] they've seemed like you guys must
have seen some weird [ __ ] during that
time okay I've got a story let's go here
we go so my brother was getting married
and dad was graduating from UCLA also
and it was in the evening and my
grandfather who spoke very broken
English he spoke Yiddish was staying
over at our house and your father and I
decided to do some psychedelic window
pane window pane don't think you
drinking Windex like eyedropper it was a
little piece of plastic and you put it
actually in your eye no I did I put it
on my tongue okay wait you actually drop
ass in your eye
no I wasn't black well window pane
that's about that car I this was bladder
anyway that's fascinating me like that
seems that seems that's
didn't hurt no wonder you're so dad cut
it at the razor blade and in quarters
you know quartered it so I took a little
bit and put it on my tongue and then I
thought you know I don't think I took it
let's do some more let's do some more so
I did oh my god oh my god of course as
soon as you do that oh my god so I was
in in the house and my grandfather was
speaking to me in Yiddish right and I'm
laughing and he thinks he's like a
[Applause]
little bit well I don't remember any of
it now but I did speak it anyways and he
was what I was laughing at him and then
I went into the bathroom because my
clothes felt tight on me so he's taking
off all night trying to put my clothes
back on and my mother's knocking at the
door saying let me just say for the
record we're not endorsing the use yeah
I drug be responsible don't do it at all
yes these are just stories mistakes that
we made be ready or yeah yeah this is
not an endorsement don't as well I
remember like your parents left and then
we thought oh it's safe it's cool to do
it and then they get in the meantime
like I'm on a full tab of windowpane
mom's freaking windows in the bathroom
undressing her parents come home now I
have to completely be straight and they
go where's Donna psycho she's in the
bathroom she's having some problems and
try to maintain that I'm perfectly
straight all the while I'm just how my
brains are right or one time we went to
Burger King and I remember the walls on
the floor the walls seemed to be melting
and the floor was like you know up and
down it was like it was I swear I
frequently do you guys take that stuff
back I've only taken it twice really
yeah that was dad how many times have
you taken it
is my mom listening to this why maybe
three times maybe for me
may 25 times 25 yeah I thought you told
me like 50 huh I don't know let me think
well there was the one time yeah no I
one time in Burger King one time at
Mom's house yeah well and we were into
you know ketamine which was just like it
was actually the case a psychotropic
drug that they gave to extremely
schizophrenic which are now they call
them they give it to people to bipolar
people so it was a drug that was
developed for people with with severe
psychosis and no one really knew what it
was and one of my good friends is
working at UCLA Medical Center and
brought home up little injectable
prescription vial of it which is I don't
think you're supposed to do that by the
way you are not know so pop the top open
I did half Oh what the hell what dosage
on this that's why if your father had
grown up with why that is really just
yeah dad that is very reckless very
reckless your father was very sick
seized it was what is it I'll take it
what's that experience was really
interesting you know I we were at my
friend Joel Joel cave shoutout to Joel
in Mexico their dad had her listening
someone is telling Joel this is someone
I hit Jones Hebrew school mom is openly
hostile to your friend Joel Joel Howard
my joel was a the greatest bullshitter
of all time this guy could go from being
totally out of it
quaalude it out to being able to talk
right as rain we got he was driving once
I when mom and I were separated for a
while
Joel was living in a in a place right on
Pacific Coast Highway in Malibu so if
you know Malibu and of all it was a
a quarter of mile from moon shadows and
that's right on the beach and this
apartment is the ocean broke right under
the apartment you're on stilts looking
over the Pacific just amazingly
beautiful place I cut your hair on the
patio and so you know quaaludes were
popular than shout-out to quaaludes get
them anyway you can't get this anyway it
was it was an interesting drug and Joel
had done like he would do drugs to the
point where you'd have to almost slap
him to wake him up and he's driving down
Pacific Coast Eye when he's weaving all
over the boat it was like let me drive
let me drive no I'm fine I'm fine and
Malibu sheriff's who have authority in
that whole area there come up behind us
turn on the lights pull us over get out
of their car walk up to us in the
meantime Joel gets out of the car
walks up to the left front tire and
starts kicking in and the sheriff's come
over and Joel New Orleans because they
Joe what's happening cuz this goddamn
alignment I just had this fixed and he
had gone from almost being comatose to
now being able to [ __ ] in these
Malibu Sheriff's by telling him oh mice
handling is all you know my car's all
messed up they go all right and it's
just like you know be careful drive
safely go back home that's pretty
amazing I reminds me of uh Ricky from
Trailer Park Boys this character in the
show is always that he always drives
drunk and they always talk his way from
the police in the most ridiculous way
what does that guy do today did he put
those skills to her you're like he's in
Mexico like a wanted man he was
incredible with women when I was living
there he was actually dating Elton
John's the ex-wife of Elton John's
manager I was like okay Elton John
doesn't have yes you know or maybe
adopted kids but I don't think well the
managers to show you how much that I was
paying aldea his managers ex-wife in
alimony was getting something like ten
thousand dollars a month in alimony
which he was you know putting all up her
nose of course which is what people did
the best of times
yeah his best at times worth the time
but it was you know amazing living there
because you never knew it was life on
the edge
sounds like a great time
it was her good good memories there were
bad memories too like being called up at
1:00 in the morning because he was at
what was the restaurant that was on
Malibu pier Alice's Restaurant
yes job called me up at one o'clock in
the morning I'm sleeping it goes Gary
there's three guys here that want to
kick my ass I need you need to come here
so you you you Kraus out of a dead sleep
grab a baseball bat get in your car
drive down there now of course you're in
in you know fighters certainly your
adrenaline is just freaking out so I get
in there you know get my baseball bat
walk I was like the guys had just left
thank God but it was always there
probably was no one there no he had yet
enemies yeah no he was he was a big
mouth he could be charming man it sounds
like you're lucky to get it make it out
of there alive well it's amazing that
all of the friends I grew up with we're
all still alive much to our surprise
well except for you're a real Hamilton
croute bruiser cruiser gangster out
there yeah dad wasn't a gangster but he
had some friends that were kind of
gangster the valley I heard a story I
remember you tell me story about how you
were like tripping super hard in your
bedroom oh yeah that was the night of
that one night that I when I was in the
bath for the same night it was the same
night and Tad left you there yeah well
he had to was time to go home and the
only thing I can the only way I could
keep myself saying right I just clean my
[Laughter]
she's gonna clean this as soon as
workout you know would be a great I want
to show I want to show my mom that video
I showed you I'd be a great way to end
it all by the way did you guys like when
I sent you the percocet song percocet
yeah
after recent right surgery like how are
you feeling and she sent like this uh
she was like the one about the magic the
magic table that cleans itself ooh that
sounds like right right up my alley I
love this guy I saw it I immediately
said to EULA
okay wait you know it's my laptop
walking right now no it's fine
magic how you guys doing we're gonna
wrap it up [ __ ] I want to show you guys
this not we're doing great
all right watch the sketch moments on
the TV okay what magic coffee thanks
even he should even cook your own dinner
for once I've been at work too you know
and what now I get to come home and pack
the dishwasher and then unpack the
dishwasher and cook dinner and you know
what I can't continue to live like this
place mainly relax it's gonna be all
right
how
here I'll just show you okay I've been
doing this since you moved in see this
basket thing I don't know how it happens
if it's the house or one but any dirty
clothes you put in this basket
somehow the next clean and in a perfect
bowl in your bed but it just keeps
happening so I didn't tell you I didn't
you are insane try it you say unless
it's only chosen me see I don't know
wait
there's other things too plates cutlery
pizza boxes dirty tissues anything you
leave on this coffee table just vanishes
overnight I mean sometimes I'll see how
far I can push this thing in obviously
oh just vanished
that's magic no she wouldn't have left
me this what I think happened I heard I
get up in the middle of the night to get
a drink or something
she must have fallen on pretty great
Aussie Aussie Aussie oi oi oi bandung
today
are you insane no he's not insane this
is good stuff
I don't know if this is a cancer reload
yeah this is some cancer we upload
treadle and [ __ ] you guys trend to blend
didn't make this video I guarantee it
they got a million and a half well -
it's not trend blend goddamn it I refuse
to believe the trend anyway let me let
me try to find this guy magic coffee
every husband says I do the vacuuming
yeah the floors don't magically make
themselves but youtube is so [ __ ]
oh here you I think this is it what
everyone give this guy his due credit I
think this is him Troy Kenny think this
is it Aussie Aussie Aussie
and see if this is him just for
reference he's collected show me the
face that's him yeah go to Troy Kenny
was a great sketch so yeah no I I saw
that a media I was like too real
well here's the here's the problem with
me like I'm I'll do the dishes and I'll
do my laundry and my is no dishes left
my measure up when it's time to clean up
is on a different scale than you it's a
gender thing I mean no it's a Gary thing
they got it from you there's no there
are some clean men out there believe it
or not I'm not one I mean I'm clean
Isaac is actually really clean are there
any straight men seem to skew more to
the female side yeah but now we're gonna
get shut down and rated by the social
justice movies anyway I like it's time
to do laundry when I'm out of underwear
it's time to do the dishes when there's
no dishes right that makes sense
well I am the one that usually puts the
dishwasher on though I don't think mom
has more than twice vacuums we vacuums
ELA when I say are you gonna vacuum or
what do i do what do i do are on the
house
girl on the house I definitely pick up
my clothes pretty often put them in the
best way uh yeah usually I I like cook
yeah Aiko that's true I was genuinely
wondering saved your ass there thank you
yeah you've got this all right that
comes from my side of the family
speaking of cooking I'm hungry
Wow let's do all let's just take should
we do like a Q&A or just wrap it
Q&A I like you yeah yeah so let's take a
short break and then we'll come back for
some Q&A I'm gonna go pee weird it evens
parents meet guys and remember if you
leave something man I don't know what's
gonna happen but I just have a really
bad feeling about it if you leave I just
have a really really bad feeling about
what's gonna happen so don't leave
thanks guys for joining us hope you all
had a lot of fun
so laughs some gas a couple gifts oh we
have this present maybe I'll open your
present I'll be good so it's my birthday
coming up in June end of June my mom's
from I mean she just came in with some
presents they speed you I have something
for you guys too but I think I'll do it
off the stream I'll tell you guys when
we wrap it up people might try to steal
it you can't steal it
oh but you guys probably will appreciate
it sounds like one of Gollum's riddles
you can't steal it it's steal you can
feel it in your pockets
by the way Sean Sean bellick was saying
hi to you guys
oh well yeah that'd be worse he is
listening do I need to do like we're
back or whatever also dunno okay we're
we're back so my birthday is coming up
or at the end of June really soon should
and my mom brought me some presents she
want yeah okay both my parents brought
me some presents so let's see what we
got here I also have a question for
everyone I bought this red hat can I
wear it or did Trump ruin the Trump has
no it doesn't have the horrible make
America great again or anything yeah
horrible lying bullsh when she got tone
it down what this has become a political
show it's not I probably kosher - when
did you wear a red hat oh my god make
America great again there are mostly red
do not wanna make I do that would mean
not having from as president see you
started it people are saying it's pink
it it looks pink for some reason on
camera but it's actually it's like
really right it has a pink hue to it
it's gonna go cuz you could have red
that is a little bit of orange
I've always known that you Lowe's or
white supremacist
put a swastika on there all right so I
can wear it yeah you can wear yeah yeah
we got that other way yeah all right
okay so what is this a board game it is
are you kidding me
that is actually a brilliant gift for
brothers this has in it yeah a great
gift
we're gonna have to bring that amazing
game off the great that I wanted and do
it I'm gonna actually legitimately do
such a great job this is old wood it's
no Lance Stewart Gardner yeah don't ask
cardboard and sharpie
it's like risky with the old wooden
people know this is a classic well that
way that's a ghost story
no no no you're misunderstanding me for
my part no you had started talking about
ghost stories wait wait that's a it's a
vintage we thought you just had this
laying around so before we did the Lance
I bought I said to dad you know what
that would be really good those stories
that is cause because it has something
to do actually there so that is amazing
I can't wait to use this cuz it seems
like such a crock of crap I can't wait
to test it out it has to be just don't
try it with your eyes closed cuz the
sums reason the spirits seem to feel it
less when your eyes are closed
what is Lance Stewart full of [ __ ] and
everyone who was a teenager and did it
we do our stories yeah pop the other
women did you
really is it actually spooky to do yeah
it's funny you turn the lights off and
you do yeah you do you have it overnight
with your girl but it's supposed to be
like five people not to everybody puts
their hands on the board and you so did
it actually move yeah not an endorsement
but if you do acid and then do the Ouija
board super effective square what is
this like more Lance Stewart themed gift
I love this package it's cool is that
part it's not original it's an old one
we got a I mean if you're trying to sell
like spooky ghost [ __ ] like there really
cook understated approach to them
Oh 8-ball that's fun magic 8-ball I
loved I thank you mom and dad for the
ghost hunting pack but now we just need
post Milan who are you gonna call ask a
question
our Ouija boards fake it says without a
doubt who do I trust though it's just a
few more what's with the eight-ball
ratting out the Ouija board I thought
they're on the same team think so is
Lance Stewart a little Doughboy outlook
is good I think that's it oh yeah I but
I brought you guys a bunch of sour
Tootsie Pops and add more sharpie barf
bag
[Laughter]
what is this so I open the car open the
card I really like the card is it just
weird whenever I open a card I expect to
be I'm always disappointed chance money
but like there's just something so
wonderful buy get in card with the check
it alright alertly cash
did you put a jack in there no Ellen and
elegant much I suggested mom put a check
in there it could be empty you could say
out loud that the road less traveled but
he brought a helmet and a shiny shopping
cart and that made all the difference no
one travels through life quite like you
bye Eddy and hedger Gary Ethan you want
me to read this is it okay everything
you can always marched to the beat of
your own drum and now over 4,000,000
march along beside you
that's nice that's a really nice analogy
that's a nice poetic thought we both
actually thing that out well that was
nice no yeah that in congratulations
yeah it's not spook related which is a
little disappointing sorry but I really
did enjoy it thank you that's nice and
then we've got this bomb what's your
taxes that's the disk for your logo
that's called the DVD yeah okay I tried
to put it I have a machine that plays
tapes but it wouldn't take that for some
racing we're I don't even think people
use DVDs anymore that's like ancient
technology all right so my Betamax it
won't work on their paid imagine you
don't even know what that is okay so
we've got this is the best gift Wow look
at the resolution on that mom she put a
lot of work
[Laughter]
[Music]
then here we've got pictures from the
pop pictures of Justin pictures of
Justin I was getting it off and I went
to [ __ ] here because if it's on its
it goes on this spot okay oh you have
the death spot Oh whoever sits here and
gets indoors so I turned it off so
anyway I let Justin got a lot of street
cred here that's cool let's keep going
see on the next wave the reason why I
put h3i because I thought maybe yes
that's a wrap retro like like now like
yeah like it when you have your guests
yeah like you know that was your second
guest when you printed these did you
think that that was the page so I office
depot that's rich again what do you
think about that well because the
thumbnails just his face looks a little
thin this is [ __ ] awesome this is way
this is awesome I love it
can you tell on this drink that guy look
looks normal in this dream okay that guy
looks like PewDiePie it's super Felix
guy and then there's pictures of Felix
I think there's pictures is there a
picture with you yeah there's this one
here and here's Felix sad huh suicide
and happy good job all the emotions yeah
exactly what it is and it's gonna go I'm
gonna keep going on going it's very I
need to have to get I have to get leafy
oh here's here's the items picture it's
me
choking out it's two-sided I've got so
many pictures of who's this oh that's
keemstar I don't know who that is
this is wonderful thank you mom you're
welcome in Akane keep it going so send
me those so this is yours all right
Cheers
what do you want to keep building on
this I want to keep build I'll keep
building it you're gonna do a new
notebook no no I'm just gonna fill it up
yeah one is what I mean is I'm giving
this back to you no no you keep that how
do you keep filling it because I have
the inserts and I have I shall just make
this things I'll just I'll just have the
pictures made up and and so we should
just leave it here and there you know be
podcasting because if we actually
printed these and sold them like my mom
scrapped up with all the pixelated
thumbnails instead like a description
we're gonna have to great idea what's
our cut yeah there's there [ __ ] I think
I put 10 of them in there oh we had to
order Tootsie Pops not just cheapy
generic real Tootsie Pops welcome
yeah all right well you you want to take
some questions do you guys have like a
couple questions here one I'm just gonna
be sucking on this is gonna get noisy my
girlfriend let's uh there was a lot of
people asking about our origin story
should I take a couple minutes and say
how do you think I met yeah let's go try
to do it quick so yesterday I'll do it
my sister she fell it if you're
listening I learned some care sorry tell
it as quickly as possible his little
words as possible okay
I was in it play a neighborhood play and
I Ramon see own shout out I had the part
of Anita West Side Story and dad was out
in the audience and saw me she's a
horrible horrible story and then
sir the play was over we had a cast
party dad had just broken up with his
girlfriend and so his sister invited him
to come to the cast party because the
guy that played Jerry Shapiro who played
the part of Tony he had I knew from
college yeah so dad was going cute girl
going oh maybe the sister baby Cheryl
will be there yeah so um dad came and he
met me instead great story you are such
a horrible no but that was like a really
wonderful Reader's Digest yeah I guess
you were in a play you guys met Yatta
Yatta Yatta yeah Bob's your uncle Here I
am
and then it's such a better story than
that go ahead go ahead
so I went to the party hoping to meet
Cheryl Shapiro I had seen mom whose hair
was real long she played Anita the
second female lead she was the only one
with any Talent when they're with my
girlfriend my parents like wow this girl
is beautiful she's so talented
when did the cast party was two three
weeks later yeah mom walks in she cut
her hair so I didn't really associate
her with the same one but you know
there's a five-year difference when we
started dating I was 21 mom was 16 which
was pretty shocking back then yeah but
she walked away go back you were 21 she
was 16 right yeah a UCLA mom was still
right now it's a little jail bait
literally jailbait do you know how hard
it was to wait two years to this is not
appropriate
next question mom walks in beautiful she
was like the queen bee and all these
high school boys were buzzing around her
when she came in so we made eye contact
mother converted and I gave her the you
know come over here honey
which no man had never had the audacity
of you she came over we started talking
we kind of hit it off I ended up driving
her home but then we had kind of mixed
signals dad gave me his jacket because I
was cold which and and to keep this and
yeah he said keep it well in other words
call me you know and I'll come
was a plot yeah and and I said no no no
no you keep it you'll be cold because I
was literally thinking he will be called
I thought that was a jacket I know
that's what I was thinking it's too
aggressive mm-hmm so dad never called me
back there never caught you never worked
it should never work anyway so like two
months later I'm walking around now you
were riding your bicycle my brother
Bragg's bike up actually Donna Avenue in
the Jewish ghetto of Northridge yeah and
I see mom her girlfriend over there
walking down the street smoking a joint
and I Drive by I was smoking I said
aren't you that you're that girl I met
at the again anyway and I said oh gee
you want to go out and we went out that
night or the next night yeah and the
rest is history and I came home after
that first date and I said to my mother
I've met the woman the girl I'm gonna
marry yep and lo and behold here we are
these many years later really cringey
21 16 shame on you guys not you mom
mostly shame on you was that tough two
years wait I know what they're done you
know what I told Dad if he had done this
to me when I was older I would have told
him to exactly but I was young and
stupid Claud that's but the first time
we did it Oh God not going there please
don't
okay you guys are that relationship that
like from afar you like this [ __ ] and
now 42 years of marriage later it seems
to have work she shouldn't have worked
what what is your favorite meme from our
videos oh wow your favorite music so or
like a person that we yeah talk about
like Louise your favorite well these
cutters you make a lot of fun of salad
yes yeah yeah you make a lot of em are
you Joey
yeah Joey Joey do you know yeah
I mean you've made a lot of fun of him
it's what he was here ya know there's
that what else here let's see if there's
anything all I think the whole humongous
thing yeah that was how you just turned
his life around and you know come on
this is the man in trouble he was in you
know what your fans did for that guys
it's just mind-blowing and the fact that
you're able to to make people's lives
better is is such a mitzvah for you know
for where we're at here and what you've
accomplished so that's my favorite I
think taking humongous and just help it
come out have you been here lately we
see what I mean he's got it he got like
we raised like a hundred seventy
thousand bucks Wow I think after the cut
he got 150 because they take a
percentage and so like he's not doing
anything crazy he's living the same life
he's still gardening and [ __ ] right it's
like a real soldier seemed like the
nicest guy yeah that's why you did it
right but now he's running for City
Council
right right yet oh wow so I don't know
if the elections come up yet but
wouldn't that be the best mean like
that's the evolution of a meme my
goodness talk about a living name right
from being attacked by a social justice
warrior Seattle it was such a wonderful
it was really a cool feeling of like
making this video defending this guy
right some random guy in the world and
then actually having him on the show and
talking to him and maybe able to make
that connection mm-hmm was really a
wonderful thing I really loved that yet
to be in the position where you can
actually help mankind help people with
whatever process it's amazing you monkey
and thanks today social justice warrior
[ __ ] or we would never even know sorry
I think my dad's getting drunk yeah yeah
right we're hungry
yeah we're drunk well guys thank you so
much for tuning in it was a real blast
it was a hoot thank you to my parents
for stopping by
absolute pleasure we love doing it love
your fans guys yeah everyone's awesome
and you guys can come up to us anytime
in and say hello because we we enjoy it
yes and thank you for this book we'll
keep it here in our office we should
start we should start publishing that
it's gonna be great like every year we
publish you know I guess sign it if you
guys want to support the show but you
don't have the funds to support our
sponsors the best way is to connect your
twitch account to your Amazon account
because if you have Amazon Prime like
every American does pretty much I think
like 60 to 70% of all Americans have
Amazon Prime isn't that mad well I was
just reading that Jeff besos is closing
in on Bill Gates as the richest law in
America Wow but he's done good things
like find the Washington Post and you
know keeping it yeah so say this money
yes we're just begging you pretty much
if you guys have an Amazon Prime account
you can subscribe for free by linking it
to your twitch account it's free money
guys so some people say there's no such
thing as a free month free lunch amazon
begs to differ
cuz mom joins Amazon Prime every time
George's oh I see the 50 dollar bill
when I get the critical thing did you
join no it just said check here and no
phrases phrase thing Islam we're still
working on that if you have Amazon you
can subscribe for free one time every
month so that's the best way to support
the show we really appreciate that and
we appreciate you guys just coming and
watching love ya and next Friday we got
Stevo next next Friday is gonna be a
really big show I'm super excited to
have Stevo on we've set the bar pretty
high for Stevo we have some really great
shows scheduled in the future and then
we actually have a surprise unscheduled
episode on Wednesday with boogie2988
because he's in town for VidCon so we'd
never get nice
we never get him in town so he's free on
Wednesday so we're gonna have one on
Wednesday with boogie and another one on
Friday with Stephen so we're gonna have
two episodes next week that works
about so I hope he doesn't do anything
like drink no poisonous er I'm gonna
yeah I'll bring some love is a normal
nice yes great stories I think the thing
he put for the four million you know he
was supposed to do something very nice
about you guys going past four million
and that way you're talking about I'll
bring that two litre of bodily the lung
fluids for Steve alright thanks for
watching guys we will see you on
Wednesday which is our buggy one and
then we'll be here on Friday we're here
every Friday god bless america
thanks everyone Thank You America great
again Seacrest
[Laughter]